saint is undoubtedly one of the
most important thinkers of the occident
he himself described his philosophy
as fundamental ontology therefore wanted to show understanding the
deepest foundations of the human
world he was
interested in going beyond the individual
sciences the
underlying meaning of life his
central question is therefore what is
the meaning of being
but if we ask about the meaning of being and
thus the meaning of life,
we have to research heidecker first of all
, the
one who asks this strange question
about meaning is the person who asks the question, who
is the only
living creature in the world who can
ask this question  and has to ask if
the person is constantly looking for
orientation
that's why saint
describes human life as a big
challenge
it doesn't live itself but
requires constant
decisions but we can also miss the meaning of life
saintly ste  he
even raises the provocative thesis that
most people live in an actual
mode of existence
he confronts us with the fact
that we usually only do what
we do one goes to school one
earns money one studies business administration one goes on
vacation instead  realizing our own lives
we move in the well-
trodden paths of others
how do I know which life suits
me how do I find my
destiny the book of saints explains in 60
minutes using the most important
quotes its famous analysis of being there
in an understandable way
it kidnaps the reader  on an
adventurous journey to the deepest
structures of our existence there is
hardly anyone who, when reading the
chapters about the worrying character of
existence or about the fear of
nothing,
does not project his own
life experiences into the
structures revealed by
heidegger and himself in them  again recognizes
in the chapter what is useful and silk  the
discovery today then shows the
far-reaching significance of his thoughts
for our personal way of life